Welcome to my talk.
As you see it is called, we are struggling
to keep up.
Something brief about me.
My name is Frederik.
I work for Mozilla in Berlin.
I have an email address and so on if you are
interested.
Why am I here?
I want to make the web more secure.
I hope by educating about security.
As it reads in the Mozilla manifesto number
5.
Individuals security and privacy on the internet
are fundamental and must not be optional.
What will I talk about?
An introduction.
Then past, present and future of security
features in the browser.
For you as developers.
First of all the web and the browser.
I work for Mozilla.
Everybody says and keeps on saying in meetings.
The web is the platform.
It is true.
The web is not going away.
And it is becoming more and more featurish.
I don't know if you recall Html 4, hypertext,
linking to text.
That's not what is the web today.
The web is experienced through rich applications
like Gmail, Twitter, Facebook.
There is a graph how it developed.
I don't need you to read it.
The high level picture you should get is,
it has developed and evolved a lot.
So for example, Html 5.
Which contains stuff like canvas, full screen,
Xml requests.
And all these things that you need for rich
applications on the web.
That of course lives us with the topic Xss.
It is what the buffer overflow was in the
1990's.
Every application or service application was
vulnerable to buffer overflow.
But since 2007, the most common vulnerability
in applications seems overall vulnerabilities
are Xss applications.
Not for a reason.
Because the most popular applications are
web applications.
It doesn't leave us with something small.
It is also in your phone.
On your tv.
And maybe on the plane if you came here.
And given all these applications platforms.
And extensions.
Xss is more than these alert box, but some
way to control all these devices.
Hopefully not on a plane though.
I do know it can make your phone ring.
There are phones that make it do.
I want to talk about authentication, authorisation,
frames.
Http was stateless.
You issue a request to a server and you get
a response and you may do that again and get
another response.
The server doesn't know and care who you are.
And will not remember you are the same person
as previously.
This was solved with cookies.
As you hopefully all know.
The server generates an ID.
And keeps track what you are doing.
One of the problems here is, everything is
sent in the clear.
Of plain text.
If you use public wifi in a coffeeshop for
example, it exposes al the authentication
data.
And even more.
And bankstatements.
As we know, Https is the solution.
Some say it is example.
I have a website with Https.
There are certificates for free.
Also Google will rank you higher if you use
Https.
It is in.
When you type in the domain, it will go to
Http.
And that is even more or less undetected.
The user is not supposed to know if there
is a lock or green lock or something different.
Also Https doesn't give full guarantee.
You may have ads or widgets.
Not everything is protected.
We'll come back to this.
I want to introduce you to something that
is the same origin policy.
In 1996, when Javascript was invented and
Frames, the idea was to have something in
the web and include as a component in the
webpage.
Reusing existing code, which is good.
It was realised it is a bad idea if you are
able to include something and read everything
within it.
Imagine go to a webpage that reads the bankstatements.
It was forbidden.
We shouldn't allow that from other origins.
So you have to be on the same origin.
What is an origin?
It is more than just the domain.
It is the scheme and the host and the port
of a Url.
And we take that as a criterium to compare
to things.
The frame.
Just to make it clear, I want to walk through
examples.
I want it to be interactive.
Knod or shake your head.
Example.Com.
And there is another Url in the table.
I hope it is big enough.
Is it the same origin?
A lot are nodding.
It is the same.
What about this one?
Everybody shaking.
Https is not Http.
Http is using a different port than https.
What about this one?
About:blank.
The domain is not blank.
What is the port?
What are we doing?
What do you think?
Some people shake their head.
A lot of people are not doing anything.
It is mostly allowed.
If you open a popup you have done access granted.
By reading things.
Everything in there is basically, has been
written by you or an empty page.
It is not going to contain bank statements.
What about the next one?
I see thumbs down there.
I have been tricking you.
Internet Explorer doesn't care about the port.
If you change document.Domain, all browners
will stop looking at ports.
So, to summarize the same origin policy, it
is not as strict as we think.
It is a bit weird.
It behaves differently.
You wouldn't do it to about:blank.
There is not just 1 same origin policy.
There are multiple scenarios.
The policy says, port, domain, scheme.
And there are also so many bypasses.
Out of the same policy.
And then there is a hack that is meant to
bypass the same origin policy.
Which I don't recommend you to use.
If you want to learn more, I can suggest one
of these talks.
From 2012.
The other one is from me.
I had to write a very long thesis about the
same origin policy.
Presented in Hamburg 2013.
We'll come back to the topic of frames.
But let's go on to the present.
I want to talk about Https and frames.
It was opt in.
There is Http strict transport security.
It was invinted in 1994.
And this year is from 2012.
We have realised it is a bad idea to have
Https.
There is a way to enforce, the browser will
always use https.
It works like this.
You do start off with http.
And the client sends a request.
Server responds.
Hopefully forwarding to https.
And once it is established, strict transport
security.
It comes with a time to live.
Cash this for an amount of time.
When it has not elapsed, continue using https.
That's neat.
The browser will always use https.
What about this one?
Plaintext again.
A network that is stripping off the forward.
There are a lot of tools that are easy to
use that are doing that.
They setup a proxy.
And the user isn't using it.
There is a proload list.
Firefox and Chrome share the list and synchronise.
This contains the bit here, let's cache this.
The browser will always use https, without
requiring the first header.
This list we have in the browsers.
They are opt in.
So to fill this list, security engineer Adam
Langly working at Google went around security
conferences and said, people, do you want
to be on the list?
It is better than what you have now.
Send me an email.
And you know, this method to maintain the
list is failed.
Nobody
sent an email.
It is sad.
I hope, the mails coming in have increased.
Now there is a google form you can do it automated.
If you are using web applications and providing
them to somebody.
And you are using https, consider using script
transport security header.
Or get into the preload list.
Now I'm come back to it.
The threat model here is being framed.
What we had before.
An innocent user goes to a website and the
website is evil.
It does include an iframe.
He is clicking around things.
You may have hoard about this.
This is click jacking.
A non transparent thing on top.
He thinks he is clicking a game.
He is clicking on the website and liking stuff.
And there are much more evil things.
When they frame your website.
Here is the funny thing from when the user
is using IE.
It is forcing the browser into a rendering
mode.
And potentially legacy vulnerabilities.
Whenever there is somebody going in the website
with this.
IE will say, this is an old website.
I will use IE 7, which is about 7 years.
And of course, this is inherited to the frames.
If somebody goes to a website framing your
website.
Your website will behave differently.
Which is bad potentially.
It will look bad.
And there is more we can do with frames.
I don't know if you have Xss filters and know
how they work.
It is built into the browser, can help an
attacker.
How do they work?
The filter is looking at the request and response.
If there is something smuggled into the webpage.
The filter will say, the script has been in
the response.
I'm sure this is an attack.
It is not passed as script.
The user is secure.
What if there was static Html or Javascript
in the page.
But it doesn't have value.
Making up a fake.
And sending it to the server.
The server doesn't work with it.
It ignores it.
The browser will think, this is the same,
I'm going to remove it.
What if it is a security?
You don't want your website to be framed.
Key is to send a header that sends: Deny.
If you do need it.
Allow from this or same origin.
You know what same origin means.
It is a security problem we had for 12 years.
It was implemented in 2008.
It was only published last year.
There is much more.
A person could do to your website and the
users.
If you allow it to be displayed in a frame.
I wrote a long p paper.
There will be links on the slides.
If you are interested, I recommend you look
into that.
I want to jump into the future of browser
security.
I have to talk about frames again.
Cross site scripting.
And I want to talk about content delivery.
Which are so useful.
How do we include untrusted content?
The threat is, we have to show something,
a user upload or from third party, what we
can't control, but we are going to show it.
Or general things.
The man in the middle, could mess with it.
And we all know that cross site scripting
can redirect.
To explain how to do it.
I'll introduce you to Not so much authority.
Access to the frames that are necessary.
In system security theory, we talk about the
principle of least authority.
Only access to the resources that it needs,
nothing more.
The least possible resources.
But least authority in a browser is weird.
It has been proven that Html 5, without Javascript...
I wouldn't say.
To solve this.
There is a feature, iframe Sandbox.
This attribute makes it safe by default.
It forbids scripts, disallows forwarding of
the outer window.
No forms.
No plugins.
And no matter what the origin of the content
of the frame to the outer window.
It is a unique and different origin.
No matter what they are in real life.
If you want to mess with Sandbox and you need
scripts, you can make it weaker.
I'm not going through the keywords.
It is straight forward.
Let's go on to Xss and fixing it.
Who knows about Csp?
Who is using Csp?
Yes.
That's the problem.
Nobody is.
There are great introductions how to make
it work for your web application without having
to rewrite.
There are 2 really good talks.
If you are interested.
First one is last year, Mike West.
It was referenced by Tim.
Previously before me.
It explains it in a very long way.
A colleague Mark Goodwin went to Sheffield
a few months ago.
And tried to focus on not how it works, but
how to make it work for you.
How to make sure your web application is more
secure without having to rewrite.
A few developer tools as well.
I just want to say, look into the talks.
It is good.
It doesn't make sense for me to repeat.
As I said, I do want to talk about content
delivery.
You include a script from something that is
not under your control.
It is highly convenient.
There is something that is most likely in
the browser cache.
Other people are using the same content delivery
network.
The website is nice and faster.
But what if someone changes the file?
It means, they can execute script and change
everything.
It doesn't mean just for this webpage, but
all in the same origin.
So, the plan is, the idea for the future is
to lock it down with sub resource integrity.
It is yet to be a W3C application.
This is how it looks like.
It doesn't look pretty.
What you do is, your computer hash.
If the file changes, you don't load it.
Problem might be, the whole web application
doesn't work.
It doesn't look much more pretty.
But there is some source.
The fast bit.
To be in the cache.
It is tried to load by the browser and the
browser does all the checks.
Loads the script.
And checks if it matches.
It is not going to break.
It is going to use the source from your domain,
which is probably not in the cache.
But the website keeps on working.
As I said, feedback is appreciated.
We can talk about it later.
There is much more into it.
I don't want go through the details.
This may be an option for you.
Now I am going to conclude.
And say the browser can help the web application.
There are more improvements on the horizon.
I might want to call it chaotic.
There were basic security checks.
Provide encryption.
There are cookies, that works.
And then the web as a platform, rich application
platform, was adopted between 1995 and now,
everyone is using a website for something.
Maybe we shouldn't put the patches on top
and try to think about it when we develop
new things.
If you are concerned about your website, that's
a nice dashboard.
Gives an overview of the security features.
If your website looks red, don't feel too
bad.
Thank you for listening.
If you have questions, I will be at the Mozilla
hacklounge after this talk.
I don't think there will be time for questions.
Thanks for listening.
(applause)